you know there's a lot of people  watching and they're saying okay Nicole  Byer it's all working out for her how  did it all start out let's take you back  to that time what was your first paid  acting gig I think it was an  advertisement yes it was for Nestle  I played a very sassy fairy a sassy  fairy yes my audition was this cast nerd  was like okay Nicole I need you to be as  black as possible and if you go to black  I'll bring you back which is like what  does that mean but turns out all she  wanted me I was just like a scream  that's what she wanted so then they like  hoisted me up and I was flying around  surely you can google it yeah see that  it actually sounds funny yeah okay okay